[Applaudissements]
ces deux mamans voilées va bien ça y est
alors je vous écris que si ce parce
quelqu'un via de prendre mon oreillette
en otage et il sape
[Musique]
il est en train de me faire un
personnage que je n'arrive pas à
identifier de monsieur qui parlent tout
doucement et il est en train de me
donner des conseillers
[Rires]
et
et qui est bien de jour
est ce qu'on peut lui être un peu trop
qu'on en produit tous parce que c'est un
personnage exceptionnel qu'il était en
train de me faire j'aime je t'aime bien
je suis alors que ce sketch a démarré
j'aime bien c'est le fils de chantal
ladesou je suis arrivé les chroniqueurs
sont arrivés et on a croisé cyril depuis
17h45 qui le crée quand gerry mort ou je
t'aime beaucoup
eric je t'aime beaucoup yves debien juni
mais je préfère à tujac on se donne
beaucoup plus con c'est le futur musée
d'éviter le 12 juillet pour la deuxième
de devenir le nom de mon émission merde
ne faut pas abuser c'est le 12 juillet
yorkaise et voilà voilà
et il est en train de me dire que faut
pas abuser et dans mon cul voilà il
fallait bien que ça se termine comme ça
de toute façon
merci séries tu viens quand tu veux tu
fais chez toi bon